do you know what the real racism in this
country looks like well there
there is actual legal racism in the form
of affirmative action that disadvantages
whites and asians
in university policies and
advantages black people and hispanic
people and some other groups
so that's legal racism but you know what
racism as we talk about it looks like in
america
it looks like a jeopardy winner
having to apologize for showing the
number three
on camera that's the that's the real
racism i'm
i am serious this really happened a
jeopardy winner
uh kelly donahue just was
absolutely eviscerated in social media
because he was accused of flashing a
white power sign what was the white
power sign
he did the little circle with his index
and thumb
and then three what is it it's the okay
symbol first of all and it's also it's
three
you'd see basketball players flash that
when they hit a three-pointer
but he apologized anyway he said i'm
truly horrified with what has been
posted about me on social media i
absolutely unequivocally condemn white
supremacy and racism of any kind
people who know me personally know that
i'm not a racist but for the public at
large it bears repeating i'm not a
racist i reject whites and condemn white
supremacy
and all forms of bigotry for the evil
they are it's shameful to me that to
think
anyone would try to use the stage of
jeopardy to advance or promote such a
disgusting agenda nobody would ever not
it's not even close there aren't white
supremacists
there's like what like three people that
you're thinking there's
a zillion bigots in blm there's a
zillion bigots in
antifa there's a zillion bigots in
congress like maxine waters
white supremacy not really a thing but
he goes on he goes
during the taping of my fourth episode i
was simply raising three fingers to mark
my third win there was nothing more i
was trying to indicate
i deeply regret this terrible
misunderstanding stop it please don't
stop embarrassing yourself he goes on he
goes on because he he buys the lie
he buys the lie that white supremacy is
a big gigantic horrible epidemic in
america
and his symbol he could really be
seriously interpreted as okay symbol or
the three symbol
it could really be interpreted to mean
white supremacy and he's got to
apologize i'm sorry i'm sorry it's not
it's not about any of that
these people these race hustlers like
maxine waters they're not trying to
fight white supremacy
white supremacy is not a thing they are
trying
to make to elicit the very reaction that
this poor schlub gave them
they are trying to impose upon you a new
understanding of symbols they are trying
to impose upon your new understanding of
language they're trying to get you to
grovel
and apologize
this jeopardy winner who apologized for
making the
the three sign for making the okay sign
shows you the whole game that the left
engages
on political correctness on woke-ism
they're the same thing
they're just it's a new term for the
same old thing just like political
correctness always changes the terms
they've changed the term even for
political correctness
the trick of political correctness which
by the way is the subject of my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds which is available now
for pre-order you can also get a signed
first edition which
just throwing that out there the the
trick here
is that they politicize all of the terms
this was part of the agenda of the early
theorists in pc and then it became
explicit in the 70s when
when the second wave feminist said that
the personal is the political
so even the way that you wash the dishes
even the way you interact in your most
intimate relations that is political
in some way so now what's so brilliant
about this what's so brilliant about
it's a critical theory
which just puts this harshly critical
lens on everything
is that even if it's ridiculous even if
the idea that the okay sign with the
three
or the three point sign that that stands
for white supremacy how i have no idea
even if that's so preposterous when they
make that claim the very fact that they
do make that claim
and that other people echo that claim
means that now this symbol which nobody
has earnestly meant to mean white
supremacy now it does
come to connote that by the sheer will
of the leftists to say so
now we have to think about that now if i
make the okay saying hey michael you
want you're gonna
come out and have a drink with us later
sounds great
i make the okay sign this now could be
posted all over the internet i've done
it about 100 times in the show now so
i'm sure it's already going to be posted
on the internet
that can be posted now to say michael
supports white supremacy
and a bunch of idiots are going to go
along with that and even some
conservatives are going to think well
it's what
it's what the symbol means now this is
why the left is so concerned with
appropriating symbols they appropriated
the rainbow for goodness sakes
leftist homosexuals and transgender
people and whatever you know
leftist sexual revolutionaries have
adopted the rainbow flag
i've noticed that my conservative
friends who might be a little bit light
in the loafers you know of
of different sort of sexual persuasions
they don't go around waving the rainbow
flag
unless they're donald trump which was i
thought that was a mistake on the
campaign trail
but they don't they don't post the
rainbow flag in their twitter bios they
don't embrace that symbol
because while the left says that that's
a symbol of their sexual identity
they themselves say no that's really
that's not it that's not that's
representing something that i don't want
to be a part of
that's representing something even other
than sexual desire it's
it's a political symbol and the left
took this political symbol
the rainbow the symbol of hope this
beautiful symbol
that shows us that god's not going to
destroy the world in a flood again and
they say no this is ours now
and so now when you see the rainbow that
is what the symbol means
got to be very careful about that not
give up the symbols
to the left we need to embrace our
symbols we need to lean in we need to
offer that substantive view of politics
and this is all to justify insane
policies hey there do not
go anywhere if you've made it here this
far congratulations you have jumped over
all the obstacles that youtube
puts out for you to not see this content
but if you want to make it easier to get
the content
ring the bell like
subscribe make sure that you have the
best chance for big tech not to totally
shut you down
and screw up your ability to check out
all of these videos we'll see you next
[Music]
[Music]
time